après la communauté d'agglomération en
avril le week-end dernier c'était au
tour de la verrière d'inaugurer son
rucher dans le cadre de l'opération
nationale abeille sentinelle de
l'environnement un message politique et
citoyen selon alain ajaj maire de la
commune s'intéressaient de s'interroger
sur les conditions de la biodiversité
sur notre territoire national et
régional et local et donc on sait
qu'aujourd'hui cette biodiversité est en
danger il y à des risques de voir tous
les phénomènes naturels perturbé par la
pollution les pesticides conséquences
graves pour l'environnement la
disparition des abeilles depuis
plusieurs années et sans ces insectes
pollinisateurs
on peut dire adieu à notre agriculture
selon l'union nationale de l'apiculture
française grâce à leur action les
abeilles génère chaque année un chiffre
d'affaires d'environ 3 milliards d'euros
soit plus de 30% de ce qu'on consomme
prouve fière du rôle des abeilles par la
pollinisation
parmi la population la bei maintenant
les enjeux corde entre abeilles sont
vraiment perçu par la population et les
politiques se disent qu effectivement il
faut prendre des décisions pour arriver
à sauvegarder abeilles parce qu'on est
passé d'un taux de mortalité que
d'environ 5% il ya encore quinze ou
vingt ans à un taux de mortalité de plus
et 30 % par an
l'installation des ruches ferriérois
sera complétée par des prairies fleuries
afin que les abeilles puisse butiné des
actions pédagogiques seront organisées
avec les écoles de la ville
et pour les gourmands sachez que le miel
sera récoltée à l'occasion des apidays
au mois de juin prochaine inauguration
de ruchers sur le territoire de saint
quentin au printemps il s'agira cette
fois de la ville de montigny